ready and action
foggy night
good work guys yeah what's up guys today
we're shooting video called backhanders
oh good
famine does it all the time it's just a
goofiest move in the world so I decided
to just make a whole video about it
we're just talking about funny video
ideas and then I don't know who brought
it up but just the idea of doing an all
back hand video you're like ok this is
going somewhere it's a little spicy
shooted all in your hallway kind of
videos huh terribly war the worst outfit
to wear this summer I'm Batman
my parents died when I was six or seven
Alfred raised me Akhila
so I took it hard around when I was an
adult I joined the League of Shadows
took up the mantle and man and
been fighting crime ever since
you
so we're using our light panels here
when I got Anton Bauer batteries in
order to make the hull all Moody and
dark looking it's a Batman hallway
basically key to making a Batman
hallways make it dark found someone
light off the wall put another light on
him for edge light and take an orange
light and under light him from the side
a little bit and then he looks really
moody also we got Eli a friend Eli over
here in a bat costume so what's up
Batman what's up buddy what's up buddy
all right we're doing the well you got
two microphones on the camera all right
why isn't gonna neat okay
I'm connected to the camera oh there's
my image feed from the camera our small
HD monitor I'm gonna expose down mmm
done oops way too far sorry Nick nice
before I can pull focus we're just
running a Nereus into our small HD
monitor because tarot decks don't
support it yet pulling focus using my
iphone and a something called a hot link
it's pretty neat turn Z basically turns
the red camera into like a Wi-Fi router
access point so this I'll be eating all
our complicated shots hey who's that
who's that handsome devil to me anyways
this is how all camera should operate at
this point I don't know why people
haven't done that on every single camera
if you guys feel like you're awkwardly
going too far to the side that's perfect
and action 14 art there yeah good
I went up to Hollywood toy in costume
and if you're a day before a shoot and
you're at Hollywood put in costume
you're already in a bad spot because it
means that something has gone horribly
wrong or you're like trying to make up
for something that should be done to a
different level of quality so yeah that
took five hours of my day yesterday and
I thought you know maybe it wouldn't
work and I was kind of worried but
apparently it fits and we're gonna do
our best and we'll see what it looks
like we put the entire costume